hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video i'm going to be going over each
rule of juju kaizen's calling game and
explaining
everything in the most simplistic form
that we know about it so far going into
the start of this arc but before we get
into the mystery behind genjaku's
culling game make sure you hit that
subscribe button to keep up to date with
the latest juju sukaisen news
reviews and spoilers and feel free to
also leave a like on the video as well
as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people
but anyway enough of that let's get into
this video so with the return of jiu
jitsu kaizen coming back from its hiatus
on the 2nd of august
i thought it was a great idea if we
decided to go over everything that we
know about the cullen game and how it
works in the most simplistic form
possible
as i've heard from a bunch of different
people i know that they are still kind
of confused on how everything works
so firstly we will go around the
pretense on how this moment has managed
to come about
kinjaku previously known as suetogedo
nirotoshi kamo and brain kun
has spent at least the past 1000 years
probably a lot more
formulating this entire shame initially
kinjaku's plan was to kill the star
placement vessel and the user of these
six eyes within a month of their
respective births
this was because the previous users of
the six eyes had always appeared and
defeated kinjaku when he tried to kill
the star plasma vessel to stop the
emerging and
instead forcing the tengen to evolve
into something that could resemble and
be considered a curse
because of the constant defeats kinjaku
decided to switch to sealing the user of
the six
eyes technique instead because there can
only ever be one user of that specific
technique alive at a single time but
something that was completely out of the
control of both the tengen
six eyes and kenjaku happened the
breaker of fate himself
toji foshiguro was tasked by the time
vessel association
to assassinate rico omanai the star
plasma vessel
in which he succeeded and suddenly one
part of kinjaku's plan was complete then
again
fate intervened and ghetto a user of the
curse manipulation technique fell
into darkness and was presumed dead
after being supposedly killed by gojo
when this happened ghetto and his
technique was taken over by kinjaku who
implanted his brain
into his body and then finally the final
piece fell into place when during the
shibuya incident he used the prison
realm to seal the monolith of a sorcerer
gojo now that we have the pretense on
how kinjaku has managed to get to this
moment
let's go over the culling game what
these barriers or colonies are and
simplify the rules so it's a bit easier
to understand
everything that's going on so throughout
all of japan there are 10 different
areas that i guess have been set up by
genjaku for this culling game
these barriers or colonies have been
placed throughout japan
at key cities and locations in which the
majority of its population is located a
barrier
or sometimes called a colony is the area
in which people must enter to
participate in the culling game
people who are already in this area when
the game starts have the opportunity to
leave but if they re-enter they
automatically accept participation
in the game these barriers are linked by
connecting barriers which people can
travel through to get to other locations
starting from the bottom of japan these
barriers start in kagoshima
and linked to hiroshima which is then
connected to three massive cities or
located in a similar area
these cities are most likely osoka kyoto
and nagoya
from here the barrier then connects to
the biggest cities of japan
both yokohama and tokyo with a total
population size of at least
40 million residents then finally the
final last three locations
are sendai moriyoko and ayamori there
are no barriers
in or around hokkaido as that is a
so-called sacred land and is probably
already ascended in some kind of way
the first rule of the culling game is
after awakening a cursed technique
players must declare their participation
in the culling game
at a colony of their choice within 19
days obviously i think this is one of
the most straightforward rules people
that have been marked by kinjaku and
have awakened a curse technique like
megami's sister have a total of 19 days
to arrive inside the barrier they don't
specifically have to state they join the
game
all they need to do is arrive at a
barrier or connecting barrier because
that's all you need to actually do
to state that you've joined a game any
player who breaks the previous rule
shall be subject to curse technique
removal
this is stating that any of the previous
players who have like awakened a curse
technique must choose to participate in
the game
and if they refuse they will
subsequently die through cursed
technique removal
rule number three is that non-players
who enter the colony become players
at the moment of entry and shall be
considered to have declared
participation in the culling game
this is a crazy rule as it's saying that
any civilians and sorcerers who don't
realize that they've entered the barrier
now have no other choice than to
participate in the culling game and
obviously if they refuse they are also
subject to curse technic removal
and will die number four is that players
score points by ending the lives of
other players
which is another extremely
straightforward rule stating that the
only way you can gain points unless
a new rule is made is by killing other
civilians and sorcerers
inside of the barriers rule number five
is that points are determined by a game
master and indicate the value of a
player's life
as a general rule sorcerers are worth
five points and non-sorcerers are worth
one point
so anyone who is either awakened or
decided to participate in the game with
a curse technique is worth a total of
five points and a normal civilian
which marky may even be considered as
because of your lack of curse energy is
only worth a total of one point
excluding the point value of a player's
own life so one point for civilians
and five for sorcerers players may spend
100 points to negotiate with the game
master to add one new rule to the
culling game so either someone will have
to kill
at least 100 civilians or 20 sorcerers
to be able to make one new rule with
this game master
rule number seven is that in accordance
with the previous rule the game master
must accept any proposed new rule unless
it has a marked and
long lasting effect on the culling game
so pretty much
there can't be any rules that will
obviously affect the length of the game
like cutting it in half or stopping the
game now no one will be able to create a
rule to end the game along with changing
any of the previous rules except for
maybe adding a secondary point system
that allows some kind of secondary way
to gain points instead of killing
innocent civilians and sorcerers
but the game master who was still a
completely unknown person has to accept
any rule that won't affect the integrity
or the overall structure of the game
rule number eight which is the final
rule that we've been given so far
is that if a player's score remains the
same for 19 days
that player shall be subject to curse
technique removal
so finally for the last rule it's pretty
simple for people like yuji who don't
exactly like to murder innocent people
if he decides to enter and participate
in the game which is most likely
and doesn't manage to kill anyone after
19 days inside the barrier or connecting
barriers he will be subject to cursed
technique removal
which will end up killing him this will
happen to anyone who doesn't manage to
kill someone within a 19 day periods
with the killing game supposedly being
two months at least people will have to
kill a minimum of four people
while defending themselves from a bunch
of sorcerers and even perhaps civilians
with guns that are trying to kill them
now with the killing game and its rules
simplified let's move on to what i
actually think kinjaku's true plan
behind the entire killing game is
so instead i think the cunning game is
actually just a pretense or the start of
what kinjaku needs to do to begin the
merging of the whole of japan's
population into the tengen
the game will use the cursed energy of
the participants who are inside the
barriers
or connecting barriers to start a ritual
that will pass humans over to the other
side the
other side can often be misconstrued to
mean something else but i'd assume that
it means
die as in someone passing over to the
other side or crossing over
but like why would tenjaku decide to
merge with the tengen when he can just
use idle transfiguration
well remember mojito and how genjaku has
absorbed the curse giving himself the
abilities of mojito himself and as we
saw extremely early on in the series
mojito was able to bring out yoona pays
curse energy and his technique through
the use of idol transfiguration
since kinshaku has the power of idol
transfiguration
why did he decide to not use it for
altering human brains and forcing their
evolution
in that kind of way well this was
because of not just a normal civilian's
bodily capacity but his own curse energy
as well that limits him
as tengen explained kinjaku lacks the
cursed energy to evolve the whole of
humanity using idol transfiguration
and it is extremely inefficient to
trigger the evolution of a single human
at a time with the curse technique idol
transfiguration
this option that kinjaku gives people of
being able to choose whether or not they
participate in the killing game enables
a binding vow
on people who decide to participate as
they willingly allow kinjaku to what i
assume
most likely slowly sap away at their
curse energy
this will then over the two-month period
build up enough cursed energy so that he
can start his merger with the tengan and
all of japan
through some kind of idle
transfiguration will start to evolve
and merge with the tenkan as well but
that i'd say is only the beginning
as the tenkan himself says if humankind
evolves and if only one person rages out
of control the world will end
and this is what i think the true plan
of kinjaku actually is
as we know in chapter 136 he says to
yuki
do you understand what i should have
created was chaos that not even i could
control
the tenkan continues on to say that
there would be no boundaries between
individuals so evil would spread
instantaneously
the impurity of 100 million people would
flood the world
so you could say it's pretty much like
shibuya but on a completely worldwide
scale and that kanjaku's ultimate plan
is turning the world into chaos through
a mass culling hence the moniker
the culling game
anyway guys i hope that have stayed true
to my word and simplified the culling
game enough so that you could clearly
understand what is actually going on
if i've missed anything or you'd like to
add your own thoughts on the outcome of
the culling game and where you see the
series headed then be sure to chuck a
comment down below and let me know
also if you are new around here and want
to keep up to date with the latest jiu
jitsu kaizen tokyo revenge's one piece
and black clover content then make sure
you hit that subscribe button
and also leave a like on the video as
well as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people
but anyway enough of that for now it's
been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a bit
bye
[Music]
you